[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute starten wir mit der rundtour durch
erlass zimmer ich zeige euch heute wie
das zimmer entstanden ist immer als er
schon so ein kleiner wirbelwind dies ist
gerade drei jahre alt und sie druckt
gerne sie tanzt gerne sie schminkt und
verkleidet sich und natürlich braucht
sie ein zimmer was ihren ansprüchen
gerecht wird und was ihrem bedürfnis
natürlich auch gerecht wird deswegen
habe ich jetzt immer komplett anders
geplant als amiras zimmer schlafzimmer
ist schön hellblau gehalten ich finde es
einfach so eine beruhigende farbe eine
kühle farbe und man kann natürlich ganz
ganz viel mit accessoires arbeiten und
wir starten jetzt direkt mit der
wandfarbe bevor ihr ins möbelgeschäft
geht solltet ihr natürlich erst einmal
überlegen was benötigt euer kind
er brauche auf jeden fall einen großen
kleiderschrank für ihre kleidung und den
wähle ich jetzt so aus dass die kleidung
die sie jetzt hat rein passt aber auch
noch mit ein bisschen puffer nach oben
denn die älter sie werden umso größer
werden die klamotten und umso mehr
werden sie das eben jetzt der schrank
ausreicht aber eben auch noch in zwei
jahren außerdem braucht er noch ein
kleiner tisch mit ein oder zwei stühlen
damit sie dort basteln kneten und auch
malen kann sie benötigt natürlich ein
bett zum drinnen sprachen eine kommode
für ihre ganze verkleidung denn davon
hat sie wirklich viel und dann habe ich
mir noch gedacht bekommt zur regale mit
aufbewahrungsboxen da können sie dann
nämlich ihre spielsachen richtig schön
rein sortieren und dann eben auch lernen
ordnung zu halten und dann haben wir uns
nach möbeln umgeschaut und natürlich
auch online
und da sind wir auf den xxx gestoßen und
uns war einfach wichtig dass wir sowohl
online als auch im laden direkt die
möbel anschauen können ich finde es
nämlich wichtig dass man gerade bei
polstern bestellen bei betten die sache
noch ausprobiert mal drauf legt drauf
sitzt und einfach schaut sind sie bequem
passen sie in die wohnung und deswegen
sind wir dorthin weil man dort eben auch
eine richtig schöne fachberatung hat und
beim xxx lutz gefällt mir weil es
einfach viele marken sind da findet man
wirklich alles ganz viele verschiedene
hersteller und uns ist eben auch wichtig
als wir wollen zumindest darauf achten
regionale hersteller zu wählen
und da hat man dort eben eine richtig
schöne große auswahl man sieht natürlich
auch wie es aufgebaut ist wo sitzen die
schrauben wie fühlt sich das stoff an
lieber leser oder polster und das kann
man dann eben einfach nur ausprobieren
wenn man direkt drauf sitzt und das
ganze mal fühlt und anfasst
[Musik]
ein paar sachen überlasse einfach alles
mehr
ich mache das ganz oben geht du einfach
kaffee trinken 66 total.com nach einem
café paradies okay ich hol dich und lass
mich einfach in ruhe du kannst
[Musik]
bis gleich
jetzt schaue ich erst einmal nach einem
kinderzimmer für die eller und eller 63
jahre alt und hier so ein bett hatte sie
noch bis vor kurzem ich habe einfach das
gitter vorne weg gemacht und da konnte
sie aber schon rein krabbeln und wieder
raus krabbeln ich glaube zwei meter
brett ist einfach noch erster schritt
einfach zu groß also in zwei meter brett
und so kleines baby ein dreijähriges
baby ist vielleicht nicht ganz so
stimmig deswegen schaue ich jetzt
erstmal hier in der abteilung aber ich
glaube fast hier ist mercer 0 bis 3 und
ich muss dann vielleicht schon in die
kinder und jugendabteilung um einfach
mal
da ist ja schon so groß dafür
der stock das ist übrigens der stuhl den
ich damals für samira gekauft habe als
ich noch studentin war und ich kam nach
hause und habe sagt murat guck mal ich
hab ein kinderstuhl für samira und so
erst hat er geschimpft weil der stuhl
wirklich nicht ganz so günstig ist aber
er ist wirklich preiswert der stuhl da
wächst mit das ist der sicherste studien
es gibt da ist einfach kippsicher war am
anfang noch diese schale hier vorne dran
man kann sogar noch so ein kleines liege
bett reinmachen für ganz kleine
säuglinge und das wichtige an dem
stocker ist einfach das kind sitzt von
anfang an direkt am tisch mit dabei und
hat nicht so einen komischen einzel
tisch und wie gesagt erwächst mit samira
hat den fünf jahre lang benutzt und dann
kam eller und eller sitzt jetzt noch
drauf ich sitze auch gerne drauf
manchmal benutze ich sowieso alles tritt
leider also dieser stuhl da ist
unkaputtbar es echt perfekt und dann
gibt es in verschiedenen ausführungen in
verschiedenen farben und das ist echt so
ein ding also ich sag ja nie kauf durch
etwas aber wenn man ein baby bekommt ist
der stoffe echt ne richtig gute
investition ein still stuhl
ich hatte nie einen stuhl morath wenn
ich diesen still stuhl bekomme dann
mache ich noch ein baby aber mal ganz im
ernst vergesst die ganzen relaxsessel
ihr nehmt einfach ein still stuhl
das stimmt sogar preis
leistungsverhältnis oben mein gott ich
kenne ihr wohnzimmer und dann so weg
was will uns das universum sagen
babyspielzeug in blau und sally sally
babyschuhe fällig spieluhr caddy maxi
toll aber nein ich bin nicht aber zum
sessel weg kultureller basso zum film
aber vielleicht finde ich noch in einen
der mir besser gefällt
ich glaube ich habe ihnen gefunden wo
seid ihr da guck mal ich passe da jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht ein dass ich erst
gedacht aber wie süß ist bitte dieser
setzen der sessel in zweifacher
ausführung und dann kannst du da mit
ihrer freundin eine kleine tee party
machen die füße sind so süß
dafür so ein schaukelpferd ist so glaube
ich bis hin zu alt aber der setzen der
ist cool
ich glaube er ist schon so groß für
diese abteilung
gehen wir in die nächste abteilung hier
darf man immer nicht zuviel gucken und
da gibt so viel schönes
auch ein pate konto doch im rat werde
fragen was ist ein bade punkte ich halte
so ein handtuch mit kapuze und dann
siehst du aus wie eine fehlt auch er
würde das leben ein team
ich liebe tipis die sind so schön zu
kuscheln gut da kann man sich so eine
kleine höhle basteln und danach zu
machen
ich komme vielleicht vielleicht nämlich
mal eins mit den profis bei ella aus und
ja vielleicht jetzt aber auch zu viel
ich weiß noch nicht aber tipps finde ich
cool guckt und können sich so
reinkuscheln alles zu machen und ich war
mal mein papa verstecken und ein buch
lesen oder schlafen ich glaube aber
macht schläft dann immer da drin
ich habe jetzt ein hersteller aus
dänemark und bei kinderzimmer möbel ist
immer ganz wichtig dass wir keine
ausdünstungen haben
da muss man echt definitiv verbrachten
und die reguliert die sind sogar
speichel echt das heißt auch wenn mein
kind benutzt oder und die möbel
weismachen als kinder ab und dann früher
mal so nicht drauf geachtet aber ich
finde auch die schau nichts passiert
aber auch an den möbeln gelutscht orient
mal dass man hier sind jetzt die mehr
weiß lackiert aber wir wollen sie auch
teilweise bunt machen so ein bisschen
und dann ist ebenso wichtig dass es gute
farben sind und eben auch später die
möbel im zimmer nicht aus das ist genau
das ist wichtig ist möbel werden immer
gemessen an einem möbelstück ob jetzt
ein mobiles aus dienstes der markwert
die maximale arbeitsplatz konzentration
java hatte ich mal in der schule oder
mehrere möbel drin und das heißt mehrere
ausziehen ist das talk einer und das ist
herr kaiser und deswegen nennt muss wenn
ich dann gucken dass wir mit möbel holt
dass diese ausdünstung nicht haben und
auch sachen auf die ich früher nicht
geachtet habe die haben wir jetzt gerade
erklärt eigentlich sinnvoll dass wir
keine scharfen kanten sind jessica
hassel abgerundet sind und wissen die
wie ich das verhindern ist das
wichtigste sicherheit funktionalität und
das ist nicht so viel und so voll wird
ja jetzt haben uns das ausgesucht weil
wir können nämlich für beide
kinderzimmers consuela als auch für
unser mir war die möbel aussuchen und
die wachsen halt mit er kriegt jetzt ein
kleines bett da nehmen wir jetzt
wahrscheinlich sogar dies ist aber ich
würde es bei ihr boden tief nehmen weil
er viele klettert geschützt und da hätte
ich jetzt an straße aus dem bett fällt
daher nehme am boden tiefes so später
krebs sie schon mal merken okay sie will
doch ein höheres können wir sie einfach
auf die stelzen setzen also bei elsa was
spielte hauptsächlich sie verkleidet
sich ja wohl gekommen treiben im
kindergarten bleiben
ich weiß nicht ob noch unsere tochter so
ist oder ob eure autos sind ihr könnt
immer schreiben wie eure kinder sind
sind sehr kreativ formalen sowie samir
hat sondern auch in uns an ihrer ist mir
damals so mirabaud absolut keine legos
die spielt nicht so mit puppen die malt
bastelt
und das war es eigentlich ein tanzt und
singt und ella ist so die verkleidet
sich sind auch gerne schminkt sich gerne
baut aber auch mal gern legos puppen mit
puppenspiel zu gern aber da glaube ich
wäre ganz wichtig so eine aufbewahrung
für ihre verkleidung zu finden
das ist so was wie der kommode bekommen
ja zum zuladen richtig kannst du nix
beliebig zusammen nicht mehr
man kann es kombinieren in verschieden
hoher als beispiel nur mal das ganze
nochmal wie zum beispiel ja zu hänger
elemente waren organe verschiedenen
rhythmen die habe ich auch vorne gesehen
die gibt es auch in tiefer und schmaler
gaggenau und da kann ich dann die
rückwand einfach habe ich mit das will
ich schön war schon können wir den
rahmen weiß lassen das nicht so ganz
kunterbunt wird das sind die fragen dann
wählen wir gerade vorne die farben auge
bei ella möchte ich gerne
heißluftballons malen und dann glaube
ich kann man sowieso die farben
aufgreifen so schön als kontrast
vielleicht ja als kind war ich immer
auch der typ der typ der geklauten
weggerannt als jemand gebraucht
was steckt vielleicht glück nicht so
groß daher vierter schon gespannt die
möbel sind jetzt alle ausgesucht und
bestellt jetzt kann das zimmer in den
passenden farben gestrichen werden
[Musik]
und wir haben jetzt unser ganzes haus
auf einmal eingerichtet
deswegen haben wir natürlich auch den
aufbau service genutzt weil es einfach
zeitlich sonst nicht anders geht und am
aufbau service hat man natürlich auch
die lieferung mit dabei ansonsten kann
man sich natürlich auch einen kleinen
lkw ausleihen und das ganze selbst
abholen selber aufbauen
aber wir haben den aufbau service jetzt
natürlich auch genutzt um zeit zu sparen
ich habe auch während dessen gedreht und
die videos gemacht und es war so echt
super praktisch die ersten möbelstücke
sind schon fertig aufgebaut jetzt wird
er das zimmer eingerichtet
ich muss gleich noch mal auf einem ipad
nach schon wo was es hatten
aber ich glaube wir stellen uns einfach
mal hier ab können dass andere rein
tragen unter schrank und bett hier
aufbauen
aber es ist schon richtig gut aus also
ich rate allen die bonbons nur auf einem
stockwerk weil die treppen diesen
ziemlich erstreckt also die bunte
kommode thimister hinten in die ecke das
habe ich noch im kopf sagt die
steckdosen sind genau und den elf zimmer
finde ich süß da haben wir nämlich
dieses wissen holz füße gerade so super
den boden lassen wir jetzt noch
abgedeckt weil wir hier noch das bett um
den schrank aufbauen zu schützen wir
unseren holzboden und da passiert nichts
und später denken wir dann alles ab toll
empfiehlt ihr da eigentlich auch dass
wenn man später alles hingestellt haben
fixiert dann alles an der wand schon
richtig gern kinderzimmer genau zu sagen
genau weil gerade bei ella ein bisschen
und klettert und deswegen ist wichtig
dass es an der wand fest machen nicht
das jetzt noch mal hoch klettert und
dann fällt sie mit dem schrank zusammen
um ja dann fixiert was immer alles
gestellt haben und dann habe auch keine
gefahr
danke die sind nicht so schwer
die nächsten sessel für ella und für
montag guckte mal die sind doch auch von
sich die passende perfekt dazu dem tisch
habe ich jetzt noch nicht gefunden aber
dann gucken wir einfach noch mal wenn
man für die deko hinfahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die haben wir die gleichen mögen
also beide vom gleichen hersteller die
farben habe ich ein bisschen anders
ausgesucht die fronten die betten und so
weiter alles ein bisschen anders
gestaltet dass nur bei ella habe ich
jetzt hier noch die füße dran damit
einfach optisch auch ein bisschen anders
aussieht und ich habe diese süßen kinder
sesseln gefunden und dann passt das auch
durch einfach perfekt sein
[Musik]
also ich sehe doch man kann die möbel
wirklich auch super alleine aufbauen
die anleitungen sind wirklich super
einfach bei uns halt von der menge her
so viel das ist alleine gar nicht
schaffen ihnen derzeit ich glaube ich
würde jetzt zwei leute aufbauen wie sich
dann alle räume fertig
deswegen haben wir da auch
professionelle hilfe vom service vom xxx
lutz und dann geht es einfach alles ein
bisschen viel
wichtig ist beim aufbau immer gar nicht
aufräumen und da haben am ende nicht das
riesen chaos
jetzt können wir auch hier eine last
immer alles schön stellen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin jemand dass ich gar nicht
entscheiden kann und dann hätten damit
sehr viel platz zum spielen da kann die
bücherei machen
nach langem hin und her was überlegt die
möbel so zu stellen dass heißt jeden die
zwei regale hier das bett hier noch im
regal
sie war noch ein kleines mit dabei das
habe ich jetzt weg und jetzt habe ich
noch ein paar sachen geholt damit ich
hier fertig dekoriert einrichten kann
[Musik]
ein hübsch teppich
das ist cool
hier bekommt er eine kleine decken damit
sie nicht auf dem boden sitzen muss wenn
so was aus dem regal holt und hier ist
guck mal schöne lesestunde
[Musik]
jetzt geht's am erlass kinderzimmer
gestaltung und ich möchte jetzt diese
wand hier zuerst einmal deswegen haben
wir auch diese wand glatt tapeziert und
die anderen wände so ein bisschen rau
cluster passiert deswegen weil ich
einfach malen kann und die farbe nicht
so ausläuft am besten ist es jetzt ihr
macht ein foto von der wand so wie ich
hier drückt aus und dann könnt ihr
nämlich auf diesem vordruck einfach
schon mal vor zeichnen was er gerne
drauf machen möchte und ich habe mir
gedacht heißluftballons passen richtig
gut in dieses zimmer
deswegen mache ich jetzt hier mal hin
wie groß ich sie haben möchte und wie
viele es ungefähr sein sollen
ich schaue mir jetzt hier einfach so ein
bisschen die vorlagen an im internet und
guckt dann welcher heißluftballon mir am
besten gefällt und neben zeichne ich
dann vor
[Musik]
das wird den weg ich mache jetzt zwei
große heißt des ballons und vielleicht
einen kleinen der so in der ferne
wegfliegt und die zwei großen anliegen
nicht echte körper das ist dann die
aufbewahrung gekommen
[Musik]
ein bisschen mager crêpes und kann jetzt
hier einfach das bett so ein bisschen
markieren das bett nämlich gleich weg
und dann habe ich einfach so ein
bisschen ein anhaltspunkt wo das bett
normalerweise steht dass ich da
eigentlich tun forderte bekomme
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er hat auf das heißt mein erster korb
der kommt hier her
ihr könnt natürlich aufs ganze ohne
echte körbchen machen und einfach einen
korb ihn mal das heißt ich habe jetzt
hier ungefähr die größe und kann mit dem
heißluftballon richtig schön groß hier
nach oben gehen
und immer schwingt mit bleistift
vorzeichnen ganz leicht da kann ich
jetzt anfangen den ballon einfach mit
weiß so ein bisschen zu kodieren vor
allem hier aus warum dass ich ihn eben
auch sehen als ich erklärt sonst haben
die bleistiftstrichen noch nicht so gut
daher hole ich jetzt direkt die farbe
fangen schon mal an zu malen und dafür
nehme ich jetzt einfach acrylfarbe
[Musik]
am anfang hat man die
farbzusammenstellung nicht so ganz gut
gefallen hier unten habe ich jetzt
einfach noch mal so wie sie drauflos
gedrittelt und so geht jetzt direkt an
die wand wird schön kunterbunt ich habe
hier meine palette darf man nämlich
einfach einen teller und solange die
farbe nämlich auch noch feucht ist kann
ich den teller immer wieder schön
abwaschen
ich habe zwar alle sechs farben ein paar
habe ich mit weiß gemischt damit sie ein
bisschen pastellige werden und jetzt
nehme ich einfach pure spies und mache
erstmal die umrandung und dann stelle
ich mich noch mal weiter weg kann noch
mal schauen ob der ballon die perfekte
größe hat und auch die schöne form hat
und dann fange ich an mit farben zu
malen
[Musik]
und so eine grundierung ist echt total
wichtig denn später deckt an die bunte
farbe einfach viel viel besser und
entweder streicht er sie mit einem
dicken pinsel auch oder auch direkt mit
einer walze ihr könnt sie mit wandfarbe
arbeiten oder auch direkt mit acryl zu
wer möchte die am rand nehme ich
übrigens immer ganz gerne so einen
großen flachen pinsel
da hat man nämlich schon die schöne
gerade und kann den rand wirklich super
einfach und ganz ganz präzise ausmalen
und ich mache es auf der linken seite
man mit rechts auf der rechten seite mit
links aber ihr könnt natürlich auch mit
einer hand malen und rechts oder links
[Musik]
hier finden beide balance grundiert ich
kann sie trocknen lassen und dann geht
mit der farbe weiter das zeige ich nicht
mich hier die streifen schon mal vor
wieder mit einem bleistift ungefähr
[Musik]
zeichnet hier die einzelnen streifen vor
da habe ich gleich ein bisschen
einfacher um mit dem pinsel dann die
farbe aufzutragen
[Musik]
die linien fall jetzt noch mit einem
edding ich habe natürlich den
heißluftballon tropfende nase und ich
finde es gibt im ganzen so vollendung
alles vollendet einfach das bild mit den
ganzen schwarzen linien
ich habe ich jetzt doppelseitiges
klebeband in extra bin und hier noch so
ein paar kitschige bender
die gibt es entweder in beim textil
bedarf oder bei der kitschigen ihres der
davor alles ausgepackt wasser hat und
die schneide ich jetzt einfach zu und
kann sie hier direkt an die balance
krank leben ich finde dadurch hat man
halt noch mal so einen von 3d effekt
dran müsst ihr nicht könnt ihr aber und
hier befestige ich jetzt einfach den
betreiber direkt an der wand und darauf
dann die werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die körper sind jetzt verfestigt jetzt
mal ich einfach nur noch rechts und
links zwei seile dran und dann sind die
körbchen fertig zum fliegen
hier mache ich jetzt das puppenhaus für
ella und ich hatte ja ursprünglich hier
sechs so regale
diese quadratischen regale wird es
nämlich zwei davon und ich werde jetzt
auseinander geschraubt damit ich einen
dachhaut und das dach geht auch echt
super einfach also in dem jetzt einfach
zwei dieser würfel dem ein aber jetzt
ist ja schon vorbereitet und zwar mache
ich jetzt hier die seite weg muss man im
prinzip beim zusammenbau können einfach
den teil nicht zusammen bauen
dem paar brauche ich nicht mit nehmt ihr
euch einen meterstab und könnt dann hier
die diagonale ausmessen und dann ein
bisschen länger messen also praktisch
bis hier zur mitte dann hier auch noch
ein bisschen runter und könnte darin
holz zuschneiden lassen einfach direkt
im baumarkt da gibt es auch schon dieses
beschichtete holz oder nimmt naturholz
und künstlern lackieren und dann wird es
praktisch so draufgelegt und hier oben
ist es angewinkelt im 45 grad winkel
damit einfach beide teile wenn sie sich
hier treffen eben schon abschließen
sowie beim leisten schneiden und wenn
ihr möchtet können das jetzt einfach so
angegeben mit heißkleber oder ein
bisschen verschrauben oder macht so in
dem durch einen bleistift markiert hier
oben und unten einen kleinen strich
sieht man jetzt hier ganz gut und jetzt
nämlich einfach von hier ungefähr noch
einmal zwei millimeter länge und
verbindet jetzt gleich diese beiden
streifen und schneit dann hier entlang
so weit so gut zum schneiden nehmen
jetzt einfach ein metall lineal und dann
ein cuttermesser das habe ich bei mir
auch beim trotten packen immer ich hab's
auch in der bastelstube in der bastel
kammer und auch in der werkstatt also da
stellen wir das vielseitig einsetzen
das neue ansätze und einfach durch
[Musik]
nicht wirklich auf der rückseite hier
auch auf linie dann kann ich nicht von
der vorder und rückseite stolz ein
bisschen einschneiden und dann kann ich
es einfach durchbrechen
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
wenn ich gut war
das passt hier perfekt rein
jetzt kann ich hier hinten wieder die
schrauberei machen und die teile die
sind jetzt hier nicht verschraubt die
schraube ich jetzt einfach noch dran
mach hier rechts und links jeweils eine
schraube rein und dann sitzt auch alles
fest das dachgeschoss ist jetzt fixiert
und jetzt kommt's auf dach drama jetzt
müsst ihr einfach mit einem meterstab
hier oben von der mitte bis hier unten
so kannte das sind jetzt bei mir 50 cm
und wenn ihr möchtet dass es darf so ein
bisschen runter geht dann einfach
ungefähr 55 cm als je nachdem wie weit
es eben runden tragen soll und dieses
holz könnt ihr euch einfach zu schneiden
lassen beim baumarkt hier müsst ihr
natürlich noch die breite
das ist bei mir 22,5 ungefähr
und dann könnt ihr euch diese zwei
bretter zu sehen lassen direkt hier oben
mit so einer schräge ich habe dir die
hölzer zugeschnitten zuschneiden lassen
und hier oben haben wir diese schräge
und ich zeige euch gleich noch wie man
diese not macht und jetzt könnt ihr
nämlich entweder ohne not arbeiten das
heißt einfach beide seiten wir dran
halten einmal hier einmal da dann das
ganze zum beispiel mit heißkleber oder
mit holzleim fixieren wobei es gebe
einfach ein bisschen schneller hält oder
macht diese note rein und dann sitzt die
rückwand und auch hier unten die ecke
einfach perfekt in dem holz drin
kleber vom tier in die große mut rein
beide seiten
[Musik]
vorsichtig daran setzen
und dann hält auch schon
[Musik]
jetzt lebe ich hier oben das dach noch
annimmt so einen kleinen mini spalt und
da fühle ich jetzt einfach abtun seien
dann sieht man den spalt nicht mehr
ihr könnt aber auch ein buch zum
beispiel eine bordüre leben und was
drüber kleben aus textilien zb einfach
auf das dekorative in die lippe kann
dann ein frank rödel aufgetragen werden
da er mit dem finger 18
und dann wenn es noch feuchte ist
einfach das krepppapier wegnehmen und
acryl den vorteil dass man streichen
kann und sogar muss weil es nämlich
irgendwann geld wird muss ich aber
glaube ich in dem fall nicht weil ist es
absolut ihr geld wert ich die ela
wahrscheinlich schon ausgewachsen
das heißt la stella bekommt jetzt als
feinschliff noch eine uhr an die wand
und die mache ich auch selber ich habe
jetzt hier einen gelben teller
da ist aus melamin und meine freundin
die erste macht daraus immer richtig
coole tasche und das kann man auch eine
tolle uhr machen
das heißt ich hätte mir später die uhr
hin und hartgeld gewählt weil es eine
sonnenuhr wird und hier kommen dadurch
die zeiger hin und für ella bequem ich
dann die uhr und gstanzl noch ein
bisschen da könnte er wirklich nach
eurer eigenen fantasie gehen
und jetzt mache ich hier noch der
sonnenstrahlen und habe jetzt den teller
hier als vorlage und diese klebestreifen
außen rum
es gibt übrigens auch klebeband was
flexibel ist habe ich aber nicht da
nehme ich jetzt den klebestreifen jetzt
hier bis an den rand und klebe ziel die
sonnenstrahlen auf
wenn das so macht habt ihr später
richtig schöne gerade linien
jetzt können wir überlegen ob wir die
sonnenstrahlen dicker machen möchtet
oder dünner ob sie gerade oder auch so
ein bisschen angewinkelt sein sollen
schön mit dem finger darüber streichen
damit den lippen zwischen wand und
klebeband möglichst verschlossen werden
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich die grundfarbe von der
wand und kann jetzt lieber streichen
eben auch diese kleinen lücken hier
zwischen klebeband und wann einfach
isolieren also ich mach jetzt hier die
farbe rein streicht sie so ein bisschen
unter das klebeband und kann dann später
hat die gelbe farbe nach dem trocknen
auf streichen und habe ich richtig
schöne gerade linien
jetzt ist die blaue grundfarbe
getrockneten kann ich die sonnenstrahlen
aus marl und passend dazu erscheint
jetzt auch bei uns richtig toll die
sonne
unsere freundin halt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt mag ihr hier einfach die mitte des
tellers und zwar geht es am einfachsten
so entweder nimmt ihr einfach in
meterstab und dann könnt ihr hier
ausmessen und die mitte markieren aber
ganz genau wird natürlich wenn ihr das
mit einem schieber messbar macht und
zwar durchmesser des tellers ausmessen
aber jetzt schon gemacht zwar rund 25
vier unternehmen hälfte davon also den
radius da ich hier mit einem edding
einfach ein bisschen was rein gemalt
also die mitte markiert dann hier außen
ansetzen und dann kann man das hier so
einritzen
das machte einmal über kreuz und dann
hab das schön die mitte und dann einfach
ein glasbau dann vorsichtig direkt in
die mitte
[Musik]
noch ist durch schwester brigitte ist
schon mutter
sodann erst stunden zeigen dann die
minute die sec
das museum stellen schwer ist komme ich
später aber die us zusammengebaut und
jetzt beklebte ich sie noch meine
freundin hat hier einfach zahlen
ausgeblutet also mit seiner speziellen
folie
ihr könnt aber auch einfach acrylfarben
oder zum beispiel april stifter die gibt
es nämlich auch oder mit edding zum
beispiel also mit seinem permanent stift
einfach die ziffern draufschreiben
wichtig ist natürlich dass man sich
vorher markiert wo ist oben
hier an der halterung sieht man ist ja
ganz gut habe ich hier einfach mit
bleistift striche gemacht und eben von
12 639 erstmal markiert und dann die
zwischenschritte und ich mache es so ich
werde jetzt die ziffern anbringen von 12
bis zur 11 und bei der zwei mache ich
dieses essens bestechen also teller mit
gabel und löffel und bei der sieben
mache ich eine zahnbürste hin
er kann auch keine uhr lesen aber sie
kann lernen wenn der kleine zeiger also
dass stundenzeiger auf der zwei also auf
dem essen steht dann gibt es eben
mittagessen und nachts gibt es ja kein
essen aber da schläft er sowieso und
guckt mich auf die uhr
und dann kann sie noch lernen wenn der
zeiger auf der zahnbürste ist dass
morgens und eben auch abends cd gepresst
wird
und so weiß sie einfach immer genau wann
gibt es essen und wann sollte ich nicht
fertig machen fürs bett oder für den
kindergarten
[Musik]
hier bekommt es sonne noch ein schönes
gesicht
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die sonnenstrahlen
fertigstellen das heißt das klebeband ab
ziehen und dann einfach nur noch die uhr
an der wand anbringen
[Musik]
fertig und jetzt schreiben hier jeden
tag die sonne für alle haben wir kein
hoch wird gewählt weil er wirklich
ziemlich ziemlich aktiv ist und da hätte
ich einfach angst dass die nacht oder
auch tagsüber beim spielen aus dem bett
fällt daher hat sie in flaches bett und
ich hab jetzt auch kein zwei meter bett
genommen denn sie ist noch ziemlich
klein geratenen meter groß und ich finde
es einfach schöner und kuscheliger wenn
das bett noch ein bisschen kleiner ist
das ist jetzt ein sechziger bett also
auch größer als ein babybett weil
nämlich er auch gerne kuschelt und dann
lege ich mich ab und wird der ins bett
und kann hier noch eine geschichte
vorlesen und hier habe ich jetzt eine
lampe montiert damit sie einfach abends
das licht anmachen kann oder auch eben
auslassen kann jedoch so ein bisschen so
ein atmosphären licht der normalerweise
haben wir eigentlich auch unsere lichter
mit dem smartphone und wenn sie nachts
aufwacht und es ganz dunkel ist dann
geht da einfach so eine notfall
beleuchtung an so ein kleines blaues
licht und findet auf die toilette oder
sie rennt einfach auch mal rüber zu uns
ins zimmer
dann hat er hier drüben die aufmachung
für ihre kostüme und da habe ich einfach
die fronten lackieren lassen das konnte
ich ja direkt bei der bestellung beim
xxl lutz direkt mitbestellt und habe
halt dort die farben ausgesucht und hier
kann sie einfach alle ihre verkleidung
reinmachen
die werde ich jetzt aber noch ein
bisschen aussortieren den sie hat
wirklich viele sachen und je mehr sie
haben so unordentlich wird es natürlich
hier oben drüber hat sie einfach die
station für ihre toni box also für die
musikbox und direkt nebendran ab sondern
spiegelt damit sie sich eben auch
angucken kann die er liebt nämlich
spiegel und ich glaube so macht sie
richtig viel spaß
ich kann nicht anders sitzen das ist ein
kindersitz auf den sessel das jetzt echt
gerne drauf also die sind richtig cool
und ich habe übrigens intel esszimmer
zwei pflanzen stehen und zwar sind es
pflanzen dieses raumklima verbessern und
so was bin ich auch immer super wichtig
ich habe zwar möbel ausgesucht die eben
keine schadstoffe ausdünstungen haben
aber oftmals ist es ja so dass bei
möbeln einfach nur ein möbelstück
gemessen wird und wenn man dann aber
ganz viele verschiedene möbel und andere
dinge im zimmer stehen hat dann entsteht
wie so eine art giftcocktail war ich
immer nie so genau wie viel formaldehyd
steckt jetzt in der luft und dann kann
man eben mit zimmerpflanzen 1
die luft ein bisschen neutralisieren und
wieder sauber machen und da habe ich
jetzt bei arzneipflanzen stehen und sie
ist auch alt genug und geht auch nicht
an die erde
die eine pflanze steht oben und die
einfach hier auf der höhe und außerdem
sind zimmerpflanzen immer schön weil sie
einfach den traum so schön warm machen
ich habe jetzt hier an der wand noch
regale angebracht weiße regale und dann
einfach mit der weißen acrylfarbe die
wolken dahinter gemalt und auf diesem
regal kann er jetzt ihre ganzen toni
figuren sammeln und damit sind die nicht
verliert habe ich hier hinten dran
ihr weißes bild ausgedruckt ein
laminiert und dann aufgeklebt und soweit
sie immer welche figur wohin kommt
welche fehlt und so geht eben auch
nichts mehr verloren und alles hat
ordentlich sein und platz hier ist er
das kleine mal und bastelecke ich habe
hier einen kleinen tisch mit stühlen
natürlich und herrlich an dem schrank
einfach etwas angebracht und zwar eine
stange mit einer ablage und in becher
den kann man aushängen man kann sie ja
malen und daneben auch wieder rein
hängen momentan mal und was ist
eigentlich nur mit buntstiften die habe
ich auf den spitzer drauf später haben
sich ja auch mal einen wasserbecher zum
beispiel abstellen da haben jetzt noch
nichts dafür
und hier unten habe ich einfach
wandhalterungen befestigt die sind
eigentlich für prospekte in den a4 und
in der oberen halterung habe ich ihre
mal drin und man hat selber papier
damit sie aber auch zu mal hat und hier
habe ich jetzt mache ihr spielzeug regal
und nahm es eigentlich dazu sagen er hat
nicht viele verschiedene spielsachen sie
spielt gern mit kuscheltieren mit so
kleinen fahrzeugen mit legos barbies
ihre puppen hat sich hier sitzen und die
puppen verkleidung hat sie hier vorne in
seiner schönen kiste und wenn ihr hier
mit diesen aufbewahrungsboxen arbeitet
und hier fordert kleine bilder an bringt
dann weiß das kind natürlich auch was
wohin geräumt wird
das heißt ich habe das hier auch als
foto ausgedruckt dann ein laminiert und
dann einfach mit einem kreisverband
hinten fest gemacht und so kann man auch
wenn sich das spielzeug mal ändert
einfach wieder neues bild ankleben und
es herrscht nicht immer richtig gut ob
man im zimmer ein spaß ist auch schon
mit uns hier oben habe ich noch so
kleine buchstaben habe den namen ella
geschrieben und die buchstaben die gibt
es eigentlich in ihrem bastelgeschäft da
habe ich noch kleister geholt und noch
so seiten papier zum reisen das mache
ich dann mit der l
ich denke dann nehme ich euch auf jeden
fall in den stories oder in einem
kleinen video dazu mit und wenn ihr
gerne wissen möchte wie ich sah mir das
zimmer gemacht habt schreibt gerne in
die kommentare und schreibt mir gerne
auch was euch hier an diesem zimmer am
besten gefallen hat sich gab es ein paar
anregungen für euer kinderzimmer oder
für eure kinder dann schreibt es mir
gerne rein den kleiderschrank den habe
ich jetzt nicht thematisiert weil ich
mir gedacht habe
da kann man vielleicht ein eigenes video
darüber machen da kann ich euch zeigen
wie ich die kleider sortiere wie ich sie
zusammenlegen so dass man auch im
kleiderschrank richtig schön ordnung hat
und vor allem auch platz spart
vielen dank fürs einschalten ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen mir hat auf jeden
fall ganz viel spaß gemacht er hat sich
riesig über ist immer gefreut und ich
hoffe dass sie hier noch ganz ganz viel
spaß gehabt
[Musik]
heute kommt die schnullerfee leer
und es war packen wir jetzt alle unsere
schnuller und alle flaschen ein
die schnullerfee kriegen die flaschen ok
und die schule und dafür kriegst du eine
überraschung wenn im sinn
ja packen wir die ein los alle hier ein
und auch wenn du morgen doch welche
finde das müssen wir sind nachliefern
super mehr braucht sie nicht mehr weil
das sind normale trinkflaschen die
braucht so gut dann machen wir jetzt
hier wieder zu jetzt nimmst du die metro
und in deinem zimmer wartet eine
überraschung wir gehen zusammen rein und
dann sind heute alle schnuller weg
damals noch gucken ob wir schon gesehen
siehst du sie vielleicht ist schon weg
ich glaube die sieht man nie wir stellen
das jetzt hier hin und dann kommt die
rundumsicht ist ja ab ok bereit für eine
überraschung
noch immer drücken ist neugierig was der
lamer aufmachen
die modelle flasche
[Applaus]
mal ist da die mama ist mit der elle in
der kirche und dieser mira spielt hier
in ihrem zimmer an zimmer angeschaut
guck mal
ein zimmer auf die kisten voll sind okay
was ist da drin und guck mal da draußen
steht immer drauf was drin ist dann
kannst du immer ordnung halten
ja sag mir wo kommen die babys rein und
die legos und die autos und die
kuscheltiere hhg ist ja unglaublich
[Musik]
[Applaus]